partir le thème des rendez vous de
l'histoire cette année est intimement
lié à l'actualité ce matin les prises de
parole se succèdent les discours entre
histoire et littérature se penche sur la
sémantique du verbe la salle elle est
comble c'est dire l'intérêt que suscite
toujours l'histoire l'histoire c'est un
mouvement c'est des circulations sont
des passions partir évoque le pire de
l'humanité les arrachements des des
collectivités les malheurs sur les
routes les religions qui oppriment les
croisades et en même temps c'est aussi
le rêve c'est aussi l'émotion c'est
aussi l'idée que ailleurs c'est très
beau et éprouvé cet ex d'émotion s'est
rencontré en soi même le ressort d'un
mieux leur sort d'une création le rock
sort d'une expérience partir ce peut
être le pire de l'homme est le meilleur
le meilleur les orateurs on en parlait
ce matin
parfois même avec une touche d'humour
mais jamais un discours n'a oublié de
faire référence à la crise des migrants
que la france traverse elle aussi
actuellement partir renvoi des moments
terribles quand on part sous les bombes
quand on part faire la guerre quand on
part défendre la liberté et le mot
partir nous renvoie nos responsabilités
nos responsabilités
hommes deux femmes et deux citoyens
celle de l'accueil parce que celui qui
part parce qu'il est menacé
celui qui passe pour une vie meilleure
voir rencontrer l'humanité donc ce thème
il est à la fois très fort parce qu'il
rencontre de l'intimé de l'histoire des
très forts parce qu'il résonne avec
l'actualité
jusqu'au 9 octobre historiens
scientifiques littéraires et passionné
d'histoire tout simplement rythme hors
aux conférences et débats à blois